vingt-quatre heures après les faits
beaucoup de questions se posent sur les
causes de ce drame le parquet a ouvert
une enquête
et effectivement la piste accidentelle
est privilégiée
cet après-midi des personnes qui étaient
présentes au moment des faits ont été
auditionnés la lumière de notamment être
faite sur le moment où l' alerte a été
donnée et sur la présence éventuelle de
témoins directs du drame
l'endroit où ça s'est passé se trouve
juste derrière moi il est réputé pour
être dangereux par les habitués de ce
lac est la baignade y est d'ailleurs
interdite même si peu de panneaux le
signal ce que l' enquête ne dit
également c'est qu'il est environ 18h30
hier soir lorsqu'une fillette de 9 ans
et son frère de 10 ans ont la permission
d'aller se rafraîchir les pieds au bord
du rivage
ils ont alors l'eau jusqu'aux chevilles
il s'avance encore de quelques
centimètres
mais là ils coulent à pic leur frère
aîné âgé de 13 ans tente de leur venir
en aide et il coule à pic
également à 19h30 les secours arrivent
sur place ils mettent une heure à
retrouver les trois victimes à cinq
mètres de profondeur dans une eau à 10
degrés il leur prodigue des massages
cardiaques pendant près d'une heure en
vain à 21h30 les trois victimes sont
transférés au centre hospitalier de
chalon sur saône et leur décès est
constaté à 22h l'enquêté se poursuit
elle prendra plusieurs jours pour faire
toute la lumière sur ce drame qui s'est
joué en quelques secondes